i gotta ask going back to like the
saturday school thing in the small
community
uh i gotta ask for did you did all your
parents know each other as well
is that is that an asian thing or i mean
i think a lot of the parents
did know each other but i think that was
only really
like if you kind of grew up with that
kid
right from a really really young right
because like we had a lot of like
uh childhood friends yeah um that i
would grow up with that
eventually you know would like do the
same sports activities or do the same or
you know or go to the same saturday
school yeah
go to the same primary or desk or
whatever but like i
didn't really know her sister or her
or shoe all that much yeah to the point
where our parents knew each other
yeah we had mutual like parent friends
yeah yeah yeah yeah but
yeah i don't think it ever got to that
one yeah because i just asked because i
obviously didn't go to sunday school but
this this is how
it's saturday school saturday i'm sorry
i'm sorry
i don't pray we don't pray
let me tell you how social lighting
worked in like the thai community when i
was growing up
we didn't have weekend school right um
so like
every every thai parent would for some
reason know each other within like a
[ __ ] 50 mile radius
and they'd hang out and they were like
your kid your kid you're
you're like within the same age
socialize and now
make friends yeah right yeah and that
was basically how i knew
all the kids in like my area and
is it the same in japan as well where
you refer to each other as like kind of
like
kind of like brother or sister or like
cousins
very much a southeast asian okay okay so
it was really confusing
uh explaining this to sydney because uh
i would i would introduce sydney to like
a family friend yeah
but i would introduce them as a cousin
yeah and i would
introduce my actual cousins as cousins
so southeast asian like family trees are
just a [ __ ] mess because we call
everyone brother sister or cousins
everyone's family okay any of these
discussions
this is not me so like when you like
refer to your
cousins right yeah do you say like the
cousin that's not
in that's not like yeah yeah no there's
no distinction we just call them cousin
cousin
and then i have to and then sydney's
just like so whenever i introduce a new
cousin so she's just like
is this a cousin cousin or just a cousin
i'm just like it's a it's a real cousin
but they're all real
white people equivalent of calling
everyone your uncle or aunt i guess
oh this is your uncle i found out they
weren't my uncle and i was like what
why did you lie i mean yeah like my
australian side definitely had that
where like my dad's friends would be my
uncles or like you know my
you know but i don't think japanese
don't really do that no i don't think so
yeah yeah i feel because like
in japan especially like the the concept
of family is very much like
closed off in a lot of sense like you
really have to be like
part of the family in order to be
considered a family member yeah
it's not it's not like an italian like
hey brother
there's not anything like that right all
like the whole cousin yeah cause like
i just can't get over i mean just held
up a sign that just said incest
who just holds up a sign that's says
incest guys are
it's the incest cube what is that what
are we making we got a guest on today
jesus sorry about this show who is the
show is definitely
you're painting an innocent mind over